my mother's the witch of izalith was one
of the primeval Lords
her power came from the soul that she
found near the first flame she focused
his power to light a flame of her own
but she failed to control it the flame
of chaos engulfed mother and my sisters
and molded them into deformed creatures
only I escaped and now I'm here
my sisters what have you done long ago
we thought the chaos flame was born of
desperation a flame created to replace
the fading first flame and to secure the
age of fire for the lords
we were wrong aisel its flame was a
flame of ambition for the first flame
gave life and izalith believed that her
soul could replicate this power and she
was right but not in the way that she
expected but when the witch and her
seven daughters huddled together and
focused their power chaos was born their
flame spiraled out of control engulfing
the women and the city of izalith and
during this period of instability the
very worst demons were born but soon
after the which clearly rested chaos
under control becoming the bed of chaos
at the heart of a new city on that day
izalith learned a set of core truths
first that her power has limits
second that fire is to be feared and
third that grotesque parasitic life is
still life the first order we meet is
quelaag she is described by her soul as
a perfect creation of chaos and we see
this in her movements note how she
affectionately caresses her demon half
how she smiles with contentment and how
she embraces her parasite
ah a precious new sacrifice the children
of chaos are hungry give yourself two
quail ax flame a steady stream of undead
are attempting to ring the second Bell
of awakening making this the perfect
place for a daughter of Kaos to nest for
chaos just like the first flame thrives
off of humanity those who defy the pact
those who trespass quail ax domain may
you feel the depth of our wrong she
speaks of a pact but a clueless undead
can have no knowledge of this to us
quelaag is just another foe who blocks
our path but she was so much more than
that
oh dear what have we here
are you a new servant yes but you have
no eggs no better go along and have
audience with our fair lady except if
you lay a hand on the fair lady you
should be prepared to face my wrath
[Music]
My dear sister what is it
don't mind me
it does not terribly your visits out
more than anything I'll be fine
I have you sister but promise me that
you will take care of yourself the fair
lady is the second daughter of Kaos we
meet but she's not much longer for this
world blind ailing and unfeeling she
subsists on offerings of humanity
humanity that her sister quelaag once
brought to her with the old witch's ring
in our possession the fair lady
understands us and since Quelaag was the
only remaining one capable of speaking
to her you must be her sister beautiful
face is something I am happy really
I don't I you speak the tongue of the
fair lady in all honesty I am envious
what comfort can I offer without
speaking her tongue this egg burdened
undead was once a renowned Pyromancer
he developed spells of toxic and poison
mist which are considered to be terrible
heretic all spells these pyromancies
owned him exile followed by a terrible
infection and then led to a chance
meeting with the daughter of Kaos worse
than Undead we are diseased and unwanted
like the grime of the Great Swamp but my
dear
fair lady she cried for me and swallowed
the great blight pus
despite mistress quail eggs orders to
the contrary these two daughters of Kaos
really deeply about their offspring and
in the fair lady's case even for the
undead that carry those offspring but
without the humanity that her sister
brought her she and her children will
die they've got still I am afraid it may
be too late I'm so sorry
is sister luckily he does not yet know
that mistress quelaag is dead so he
shares his flame with you which is a
deeply personal act for a Pyromancer
because the flame is a part of himself
you have served our fair lady well let
this strength be yours before there were
pyromancies there were fire sorceries
and then when the witch of izalith
shared her flame with her daughter's
pyromancy came to be unlike sorcery
which requires a certain intellect
pyromancy is this personal primal art
rooted in this desire to hold and
control fire and then it's refined by
the acceptance that true control is
impossible pyromancy is the ultimate
fantasy we are born into dark and warmed
by fire but this fire we cannot touch
those whose fascination with fire
persists learn to hold it in their own
hand and so humanity took really well to
this ancient art passing down knowledge
from a daughter of chaos herself have
you heard of lost quelana and inhuman
witch who wanders the poisoned swamp
only no one has ever seen her so who
really knows but what if she is another
of the Quelaag sisters
Fairlady would be greatly comforted by
her presence hmm Ahmir undead yet you
can see me fascinating I am quite Lana
of izalith I am not often revealed to
walk as a flesh you have a gift
are you too one who seeks my pyromancy
Quay Lana is the eldest daughter of
chaos and she's the farthest one from
home it's thanks to her that mankind
became so attuned to pyromancy pyromancy
is the art of invoking and manipulating
fire but remember one thing always fear
the flame lest you be devoured by it and
lose yourself I would hate to see that
happen again
interestingly Quay Lana refuses to teach
the chaos pyromancy of her homeland
instead opting for the more refined
pyromancies to come via whip an effort
to control that which cannot be
controlled via a storm which displays
the indiscriminate horror of flame and
perhaps most importantly report an
advanced spell of Quay Lana that uses
fire to lure the living making them a
temporary outlet
hmm I have a favor to ask I abandoned my
mother and sisters and fled to this land
but my mother and sisters have been in
anguish since I beseech you free mother
and my sisters from the flame of chaos I
cannot do it myself
I lack the strength and the bravery but
you I realize what I am asking
but please free their poor souls what
those ambitions were misguided no doubt
but surely a thousand years of atonement
is enough quelana believes her family
has been in penance for a thousand years
and that death would be their only
comfort but is this true will you take
the word of a woman who's afraid to face
her own demons the flame of chaos is not
as evil as quail Anna would have you
believe how could it be when it
motivated an entire developed
civilization izalith architecture is
inspired by chaos its first demons are
considered priests the capra is capable
of taming animals there were embers of
chaos used for smithing there is a
written language a spoken language this
is not really a place that was ruined
because of chaos it's a place that
became defined by it and it's all thanks
to mother izalith if it was izalith
skull to create a flame of life and she
succeeded for two younger sisters and
the mother can be found in the depths of
izalith at its lowest point where demons
are born this seedbed of life is called
the bed of chaos it's actually comprised
of three family members flanking on the
sides are two enchanted fleshy mounds
connected to the center
staves staves that look awfully like the
eyes love the staff seen in the
beginning where two sisters flank the
mother in the center which makes the
center of the bed of chaos mother
izalith herself her control is evident
by virtue of our ability to undo it
because if you take out a sister on the
side then the heart of chaos breaks free
so if chaos was under control what
happened to izalith war despite izalith
aid in Gwynn's war against the dragons
the Lord of Light turned his ire to the
creatures of chaos did he feel
threatened by these monsters did he
consider chaos to be this affront to the
integrity of divine flame it's
impossible to say for sure for this war
he commissioned an elite order of
warriors who became known as the black
knights their oversized weapons were
designed to deal with their oversized
foes and their loyalty to Gwyn was so
fierce that they would lay to follow him
into the kiln of the first flame
[Music]
if there ever was a time for Quay Lana
to slip away and leave it would be now
during the war
her family must have thought that she
died for upon an altar dressed upon an
unrecognizable corpse is a gold handset
that says it was once worn by quelana of
izalith so not only does this suggest
that she faked her death it suggests
that she couldn't bear to have her
family know about her desertion and this
news of her death would have hit no one
harder than her brother this giant is a
being of ceaseless discharge born
alongside the worst demons when the
chaos flame was still unstable so to
soothe his lava inflamed sores
his witch sisters gave him a special
orange charred ring which fooled that he
is he accidentally dropped he would
never receive another and so he spent
the rest of his days in pain oblivious
to everything around him everything
except the shrine to his sister Quayle
onna desecrate her corpse and he would
literally throw away his life to punish
you so strong is the love phase family
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
leaving her family may well have been
the worst decision quelana could have
made before in a move that she could not
have predicted Gwyn stopped short of
annihilating the demons entirely izalith
after all was already broken referred to
by many as the obsolete capital of chaos
in return for their miserable lives and
along with a promise to never leave
izalith it appears that Gwyn received a
swarm of demonic troops for his own army
stray demons guard the asylum lesser bad
winged demons became the messengers of
the gods and a white winged demonic lion
watches over the sanctuary of oolacile
so it was that the family of chaos
survived and Quayle onna
deserted them all it's likely quelana
didn't expect her sisters to survive the
war but now that they have she becomes
stuck in this awkward state of limbo
she cannot return for she disgraced and
abandoned her family and yet nor can she
bring herself to fully leave either
instead she sits as close to chaos as
possible punishing herself with this
endless wandering through a poisoned
swamp she watches on so close to her
tormented family and yet given her
survivor's guilt and her cowardice she
might as well be miles away which is a
shame because quelana could truly be a
comfort to a remaining family especially
to the fair lady to her brother and to
her mother the witch of izalith please
do not speak of her I abandoned my
mother and sisters and fled to this land
now I roam these parts feigning ablution
and pretending to seek answers
finally after a thousand years of
survivor's guilt she meets us
someone who can finally break the
stalemate she likes the strength and the
bravery and we have a lord vessel to
fill I should have no they gave
everything to rest chaos under control
they ignited a culture they displayed
that they could control their parasites
and even that having a parasite at all
is a choice a choice to serve chaos and
we undo it all we rip the sisters
shackles from chaos and despite the
mothers feeble attempts to sort of swat
us away we finally put an end to mother
izalith herself
outstanding you have done very well
thank you I am blessed I've met you
please take this it is all of me we fed
quail Ana's ignorance she never got to
see her brother mourn her for centuries
she likely never knew that her sister
poisoned herself for the good of the
wretched did she know that a dark wraith
was squirreling away humanity for his
fair lady that her mother was doubled
over in pain for centuries to contain
chaos survivor's guilt is a real
traumatic condition and had led to the
death of her family he owns afterwards
the effects of all of this are still
felt without the mother chaos rises
again unbridled in a city called eleum
loyce until the powerful king and queen
sacrificed themselves to contain it once
again and even later still towards the
end of the world surrounded by mountains
of dead demons an old demon king gives
up the vestee jizz of chaos in one final
effort to fight for his species there is
only one silver lining to this tale it's
that deep within the long-forgotten
ruins past the last surviving offshoots
of the demon race and behind an
illusionary war lies the corpse of Kwai
Lana curled up to the fair lady she
finally found the strength to return
home
this video is dedicated to my patrons
because there's like a thousand or so of
you who support my stuff so that
millions can enjoy it and I think it
takes a special kind of person to do
that so thank you and hey I guess I can
now include my twitch subs amongst that
number as well twitch subs actually get
the same perks as $5.00 patrons do so
that means early access to videos and
also early access to the art that I
commissioned for the channel as well
it's really nice to be able to give back
to you guys and all of the wallpapers
this month are awesome since they were
specifically created for twitch so they
have the right aspect ratio and
everything I actually use most of these
myself check it out
and we debuted this video on twitch
yesterday and it was super fun and
motivating to read your comments about
it in real time at the very least I do
plan to stream every time I upload a new
video so keep an eye out for that I got
to get that practice in before sukira
launches in March because I think I'm
gonna stream the hell out of that I'd
love to be able to share my first
playthrough I'd also like to thank the
Perry God who collaborated with me for
this video he was responsible for the
incredible camera angles and all of the
slow-motion shots so check out his
channel in the description and there's
also two other law content creators I
want to shout out there's Hawkshaw and
loki two content creators who really
changed the way that I view izalith and
a lot of the conclusions that they draw
inspired this video so I think you guys
would particularly enjoy hawk Shores
video on the demons
I know I've shouted it out before but
that's in the description but that's all
for now thank you as always
simply for watching the video hope it
enhanced your enjoyment of the soul
series because that's what this is all
about I'll see you next time
[Music]
you